meghan markle and prince harry's son
archie is officially three years old and
now the royal family is putting aside
their differences to celebrate the
toddler's big day queen elizabeth posted
this snap to her insta story with her
late husband prince philip greeting
archie when he was just a baby that's
megan holding her little boy along with
meg's mom doria ragland and harry the
caption wishing archie mountbatten
windsor a very happy third birthday
pretty special as for archie's
grandfather prince charles this pick was
posted to his story that's the prince of
wales looking over at his grandson
alongside the message happy birthday rg
even kate middleton and prince william
who is reportedly still at odds with
harry posted a sweet tribute to their
nephew quote wishing archie a very happy
third birthday today whose relationship
really is you know at a bit of a
crossroads they haven't spoken for many
months they're not closed at the moment
harry and megan who live in montecito
california were in the uk last month for
the invictus games i think the visit has
been a huge success they haven't been
over 2 euros since 2020 and i think
people didn't quite know how this was
going to go it went phenomenally well
they had a very very warm welcome i
think everyone was so happy to see harry
but it's been reported that harry who
officially stepped down as a senior
member of the royal family in 2021
only visited the queen the meeting with
the queen has been very much kept under
wraps we understand that harry and megan
did get to spend time with the queen at
windsor castle but i think the very fact
that a meeting happened
has to be a positive sign i can tell you
that the queen has missed harry she
hasn't met her great-granddaughter lilly
bert she hasn't seen archie for nearly
two years now and she hasn't seen harry
for well over a year so she will have
been i'm sure delighted to have got to
see him and megan and how much was
discussed is is hard to know i can
imagine that she would be very pleased
to have seen harry and at the time royal
expert katie nichol told et that harry
is looking into using a mediator to mend
his relationship with his brother it's
something that he has suggested to his
father he's made it very clear that he
he wants to sort things out he wants
things to be improved i'm hearing that
he wants to be over here for the queen's
platinum jubilee celebrations in june
well on friday a spokesperson for megan
and harry confirmed that the couple and
their children will travel to the uk for
the queen's platinum jubilee next month
a source close to the royal family tells
et that it was actually the queen
herself who invited the pair to attend
the celebration adding that hrh is
delighted that she will be meeting her
great-granddaughter for the first time
and is excited to be able to spend time
with archie and lily this is the year
that we are celebrating queen elizabeth
the first and only british monarch to
mark 70 years on the thrones this is her
jubilee year
[Music]
you